i asked you a question and very quickly
you you kind of said no to it you don't
think meadows the future so you don't
think what zucker just did
the fact that the next generation of 12
year olds today 18 year olds today are
going to be sitting there hours a day
instead of being on their phone they're
going to be there under virtual reality
in a meta world you don't think that's
the direction we're going metaverse
medical i thought you said metal is the
thing no no no metaverse
definitely metaverse is where people are
going to live i mean and and this is
where people are going to exist and
interact i mean you know like right
roblox i mean it's very like it's all
over it it's very interesting yeah and
you they'll tell you i need some some of
this to buy a uh digital watch yeah in
the so that i can have i can flex with
my watch in the metaverse and you're
thinking hang on a minute uh tell me
that one more time dylan showed it to me
they said that can i show me can i get
10 bucks to buy this i'm like to do what
yeah and so and so
can can you can you zoom out and see
where this is going i mean i predict by
the end of the decade this is so
pervasive that people want to take a
psychedelic to have a human experience i
agree
this is going to be you know the drugs
have remember the 80s is like the coke
era and then the 90s is like you have
these eras right and so people are going
to crave that type of
we're human beings we're humans like you
can't get away from it so remember right
now your kid at 10 years old mask okay
they're going to school that no one can
see their face you better wash your
hands all the time don't play with any
other kids stay home stay in your room
and what's happening i'm anxious
kids are having like all these problems
like i'm anxious i don't know what to do
i can't talk to anyone the kids can't
talk i mean i'm pat i'm sure your kids
can then you go home you go online you
can talk because because you you're you
you have this type of engagement with
your family but it's like the average
kid in a dr horton home and a
subdivision that's locked in his room
covered in sanitizer he's up there
metaverse is his is his one
and so what where is this headed is you
can see a society that goes down this
type of path and imagine from the
controlling elite you're now you're all
your your whole life is infinitely
controllable because you've you've
abandoned all your critical thinking
skills i mean all einstein like carl
sagan all these guys said the the
technology evolves to the point where
people abandon the ability to think and
to be human and to have critical so did
ted cruz
critical thought you know and you can
see this happening right now i mean
i i'm like you i go somewhere and i'm
like how you doing and people are
absolutely
terrified i mean
and that's a new concept this is not
that that didn't exist before because
yeah yeah but this wait wait wait so i
mean i agree with you 100 and i i think
society is going to really break into
like two different realms they're you're
gonna have the the the real and the and
the pseudo real the virtual in the real
world yeah so that but that actually
goes against your art exactly i mean the
idea of his kids are going to interact
with digital currency far more in their
life than they're ever going to interact
with
will there ever ever be a time where
people say holy crap my entire existence
is controllable
yeah i don't know can you pull that back
please i don't know the book people will
there will there will there ever be a
point where
there's no there's somebody is though
will they care because
you told me two years ago that the city
of new york and the people inside
would allow somebody to shut their
businesses down yeah would allow
somebody to curfew them and muzzle them
would allow somebody to essentially put
soft martial law on the city of new york
yeah for years i would have said you're
out of your mind and he'll be people
hanging from the bridge and it didn't
happen and matter of fact they agreed
with yeah and what's amazing is you ask
them what makes new york great they're
like capitalist center of the world and
you're like really here's a question
though it's crazy here's a question
though yeah man what's new guys what
what do we like but this is what's new i
can i can actually answer that because
i've thought about this non-stop what's
new is that
the control is now comfortable
when our forefathers got taxed and they
didn't have representation they were
there was discomfort there wasn't
constant distraction right now you can
be controlled your life is controlled
but you're in an air-conditioned room
you have access to a metaverse
let me push back okay what happened in
what happened in 1913 1930 got an income
tax taxes were introduced okay but only
for the millionaires dude there's five
of them fine but but here's the question
okay let me let me go to a different
timeline for you and then they what
happened they didn't like it so they
created them to get their money back
what happened in 1862 1863
1862 where it was a civil war was okay
and then lincoln came out and he said we
need to have taxes because we need to
pay off the civil war
once we pay it off we will get away with
taxes right sure and the american people
said what
okay we trust you bro okay fine
i'll pay some taxes so he put some tears
it was by the was minimal like two to
six percent six to ten percent and he
says once we pay off the debt for civil
war we'll stop paying taxes but you know
what happened to taxes do you think it
ever went away never go away here's the
thing it did go away in 1872 under
lincoln in 1872 income taxes went away
okay but let me explain to where i'm
going with this 13. cigar taxes didn't
go away i mean the income tax that they
had but it was tax
income taxes which was the main one that
collected most of the money so that went
away which was the model guys listen
like imagine if i come up and i say guys
we just raised 50 million dollars
to do this
look here's what we got with the movie
it's going to blow up i need you guys to
take a 10 pay cut and your income i'll
take 100 pay cut you guys in i hope you
do it and we say okay let's do it and
then but at the time same time if we
come back we'll increase it 15
the point is for the longest time people
have said
all right cool
withholding tax that you know the whole
withholding tax withholding concept you
know who came up with that a guy named
milton friedman and he said it was one
of the biggest regrets i make in my life
that i agreed to it what i'm trying to
say is historically we've all been like
majority of the world's been like okay
there's been a select few of 10 of
people that are willing to fight back to
bully the bully and everybody else had
to make a decision to see what's better
at presenting their argument but the
point i'm trying to make here with them
on the meta side and i want you to push
back on this as well on the meta side is
the following
if we are going that direction there's
nothing you can do about it on the meta
side to change it we can't change that
direction we're going in that direction
it is already too late a guy pitched a
meta world for valuetainment to me
three years ago antonio who was here
with us and i'm like what and then now
he came back and now we're having a real
conversation about it so if we go to
that route
this means what sure yes this is
well you'll just buy a representation of
that in the valuetainment world
you know you'll have like a gold mine
that has little trucks moving like that
becomes an nfl
they're selling digital real estate now
there's digital land
someone just bought a multi-million
dollar yacht on a megaverse
it's hanging out on a fake yeah i'd
rather go to a real yacht
will there ever be a time where
maybe you're taking the mushroom trip to
have a human experience and you say sure
wait a minute like i had a thought and
my social credit score went down and now
i don't have access to the valuetainment
metaverse because i'm being punished
they're trying will it ever happen and
what will you want in security when
you're trying to create an environment
of insulated insecurity you're fat on a
real yacht you're not fat on the
metaverse shot you're short in real life
you're not short in metaverse you can't
dunk in real life but on nba on an nba
2k you can dunk you can 360. so there's
this idea that that the real world is
unfair so now going back to your point
these people are able to get control
because they're making life fairer for
everybody give up all my control in the
real world because i don't like the real
world i don't like who i am i don't like
the money that i make i don't like the
way that i look juxtaposed against this
i don't like the girlfriend that i have
the metaverse is the world that i want
this is my idealized version of self
so i will give up everything in the real
world and as long as you keep me safe
and as long as i can have access to my
id like
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]